comme vous êtes docteur quand même je
vous faire une petite interview check up
[Musique]
dont bernard kouchner vous êtes chez le
docteur a redit son conducteur
bonjour je vous ai pas fait attendre ça
va non ça va bien qu'est ce qui vous
donne envie de vomir dans le monde
actuel lement son chat qu'est ce qui
vous fait mal au coeur dans le monde
actuel la pression en france qu'est ce
qui vous donne mal à la tête
la vie quotidienne je venais la vie
qu'est ce qui vous donne des boutons
dans le milieu politique
la même chose un ulcère je vous pose la
question c'est pareil
ah non elle aussi à ça fait mal à leur
sexe comme un ulcère alors dans le
milieu politique aujourd'hui en france
cette façon de croire que quand une idée
vient de l'autre quand elle est
forcément mauvais personne n'y croit et
pourtant on feint toujours de céder à
cette espèce de guerre civile oui je
crois que ça c'est dommageable pour le
pays et pour l'estomac et page thomas
particulier mais pour le pays surtout
quelle femme politique vous donne la
fière aujourd'hui en france roselyne
bachelot ah ouais vous excite
non je les aime bien ah oui j'ai des
convictions
pourquoi vous l'aimez bien parce que je
les aime bien je la trouve sympathique
et franche elle est marrante ce qui fait
le plus de gaz
ces salles non non non pas du tout bon
jeu le bien non je trouve absolument
primesautière a merveilleusement habillé
d'ailleurs vivent là c'est trop simple
je suis déjà et je n'entends non je suis
à ce que je trouve de compliments tu le
compliment tout ça bien réveillé la
légende et cria marque l injustice
aujourd'hui en france vous fait vraiment
mal au cul je crois que cette mesure qui
consiste à donner moins d'argent aux
jeunes femmes ont sans fin pour la
première naissance aux jeunes femmes
enceintes qui ont un besoin terry parce
qu'elles n'ont pas de ressources me
paraît particulièrement inappropriés et
scandaleuse
voilà bah écoutez le check up est
terminée ça va ça va là bas ça va vous
voulez que je vous prescrive un peu de
viagra com
hier fois non mais il m'a prescrit un
truc comme ça tu l'avais je n'ai pas
pris cette idiotie
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu